hey everybody it's Mike from motf flows
and welcome to today's video you know
today is uh Tuesday January 10th 2023
and you know we're 10 days into the new
year and this is our 10th video you know
we're trying to get them up every day of
the week for you guys even on the
weekend so be sure to subscribe to the
channel so you'll be notified when a new
video gets posted and you know again you
know if you got any questions be sure to
put them in the comments you know
sometimes I'll reply to them and
sometimes I'll try and make a video on
them if it needs a little bit longer
explanation and you know that that's
what today's video is sort of about
because you know there was a very
interesting question that uh someone
asked and I was I was going through some
of the the comments on some of the
recent videos I for some reason I
couldn't find that question again but
basically it was the question was um you
know why am I looking at the footprint
diagonally you know in the you know the
bid against the offer and why not just
look it at it horizontally um the volume
basically they traded on the bid at a
price versus the volume traded on the
offer at the price and really it it goes
back to you know the markets trade in a
two-way auction so you know if you're
familiar with the the
dome right you know there there's a bid
there's an offer right it trades um like
for example it's 30 what is that 3939
and a half bid at 39 um 3975 offer size
of 14 by5 and markets you know go up or
down but they they trade in a two-way
auction right there's a bid against an
offer aggressive uh buyers will buy at
the
at the offer aggressive sellers will
sell into the existing bid and Below um
this is just my testing and recording PC
so I don't have the depth of market up
here but you know you're usually going
to see you you'll on my trading PC I'll
have all the volumes filled in because I
have the depth of the market on that PC
now if you're looking
at how a market moves right remember
markets are a two-way auction and you
know we don't really think about it very
much in the sense of we go to a grocery
store and you know you see a fixed price
on on the shelf or something right a
loaf of bread it's $299 um you know milk
is you know $5 and and a dozen eggs now
is like a 100 bucks but you can't hangle
at those prices now when it comes to
other things that we're that we buy you
know cars houses um you know there's a
offer price and we come in there we
either pay the offer or we work a bit in
a sense you know say well you know
you're looking at um the realtor.com you
see a nice house you like it's a half a
million dollars but you're like yeah I
like the house but you know what I got
to do this to it I got to do some more
work and I got to put some more money
into it so you know what even though the
house is offered at half a million
dollars I'm going to bid $450 and see if
this gu is going to come down to my
price right so you know that's how
things in real life trade in a two-way
auction
now can you look at you know the volume
trade on the bid the volume trade at the
offer at a price like 598 against 477
yeah of course you can um I just find it
much easier to look at it in terms of
the 2A auction right when the market was
14 bid at
15 you know 243 traded on the bid at 14
477 traded at 15 now of course you know
these bars are going to keep going up
and down until they complete but once
the bar completes then I know that you
know at this price when it was 16 bid
only 13 contracts traded when it was 17
offered um 112 traded and I know that
when it was 17 bid there was 154 traded
nothing traded on the offer up here at
18 now again you know there's different
types of footprints that you could
actually use if you want to see what the
volume is at price now I I know some
Traders out there they they like to use
an actual volume footprint and they just
look at the actual volume that's traded
at the price and let me just uh change
that here for you so you can see um so
this is a bid ask footprint right you're
looking at it
diagonally you could use the volume
footprint and that will just give you
all the volume traded at
Price okay this but this is combined
right so this is both the volume trade
on the bid the volume traded on the
offer okay so you know you can see here
it was 266 51 1075 521 1 657 832 um you
know I know people they like to have a
little visual sometimes they like to
have a profile showing up on the bar and
sort of look for you know these micro
volume
profiles um you you could look at the
Delta which is the Delta at price at the
bar I did a video on this uh pretty
recently actually about a week or two
ago um you know on how you could use
some of these other types of footprints
but this is the Delta here let's pull it
up here there are certain things that
you can pull away from you know certain
types of bars but again it takes time to
find the type of chart that you're used
that you're going to use that you're
comfortable with right that you can
utilize the information that you're
looking at I spent a lot of time looking
at a Delta footprint I mean like years
in addition to looking at a bid ask
footprint and you know there's certain
things that I like to look for on a
Delta foot footprint right I mean a bar
like this right is very obvious see this
green candle so this is a Delta
footprint so at 13 there was more volume
traded on the offer at 14 more volume
traded on the offer that's why you have
just the volume being printed here 57
which is actually the Delta between what
traded on the bid at 14 and what traded
on the offer so it's got positive Delta
57 just says here you got positive Delta
of 38 202 206 31 43 27 and 11
now I'm not going to get into all all
you know what you should look for on on
sort of these different types of charts
but you know really it's about finding
the type of footprint that is
comfortable with you that you can
understand exactly what you're looking
at in the footprint so just sort of to
get back to the volume footprint right
the the volume that's traded on the bid
versus the volume traded on the
offer how I would use it if I was just
looking at that information is I'd be
looking for the
bars that have very little volume at the
top or at the bottom depending on if
it's an up bar or a down bar so for
example okay this Market is selling off
nicely this red line is the low of the
day we're making new low new low new low
got a Divergence bounce up and we're
just sort of hanging around here right
this 16 level 1286 first time you trade
it at
16 volume total volume 825 what was
traded on the bid what was traded on the
offer second time came up you know this
is a 5 minute chart so 10 minutes later
he came up traded one
contract 5 minutes later the next bar
finishes you trade two contracts now
this is bonds this is a f minute chart
and when I see you know very small
volumes like one or two it's telling me
something it's telling me you know
Traders aren't interested in taking it
higher now I would sort of use the same
information if I was looking at a bid
ask
footprint but when I start seeing you
know very small volumes on tops of bars
and the bars closed on their low well
it's telling me you know at the upper
end there was nobody interested in
taking it higher anymore right first
time you came up here there was nice
volume now it's struggling struggling
and the market continues down just as if
let me go back
here right you know again Market is just
powering down powering down powering
down you know I've got a six right on
this green candle I've got a five down
here okay which candle would I be more
interested to buy well I would never be
interested to take a trade right before
7:30 but after this low is made here at
740 you know I got this nice green
candle I got five down here okay we
close up on the high as opposed to this
bar we close sort of back in the middle
right I'm always looking at the
relationship of where price is trading
relative to where the bar is closing
especially if you're on a Time based
chart um or a range based chart or any
type of chart right you want to know you
know are we closing on as our extreme
because you know chances are if you're
going to close on your extreme chances
are you going to continue in that
direction now of course as I said that
this next bar came back down but as it
came back down what do I see in terms of
just raw volume well I know the first
time we came down there was Heavy volume
right it traded 59 but then it ran into
a th000 in this next bar got through it
ran into another 800 now as it starts
coming back up I can see here at 22
there was 787 traded total at this price
both the bid and the offer I know it
gets a little confusing because you're
looking at the total volume for what was
traded on the bid and the offer and it
just puts it on one side I mean it has
to just put it on one side of the chart
CU it's just total volume you can't put
it in the middle of the bar one it's
going to be hard to read and and two
it's you know from a programming
standpoint is just uh not possible um
and then you get another heavy volume
here so you know I know that generally
if I'm looking at bars that have heavy
volume towards the bottom I know there
was some sort
of
support okay and people say well how do
you know right because it's just telling
you the volume it just shows 787 it
could been um you know two contracts on
the bid and and
785 traded on the offer you know people
say well isn't that indicative of strong
selling well at the same time it's
indicative of strong aggressive buying
if it was actually two on the bid and
785 on the offer I know that somebody
came in and scooped that all up right
they just ate
it and Market went higher just as if
this was five that traded on the bid and
8 70 traded on the offer this total of
875 I know that yeah sellers were coming
down offering out Supply but somebody
just came in and bought it all and now
we're trading higher just as you know
when we get up here sort of you hit this
I guess you'd call this a swing High
start coming off and you see some decent
volumes in here 897
952 okay I don't know you know I can't
really gaug one way or the other if it's
going to be um supportive buying or
resistance selling that's coming in here
because again I'm just looking at the
raw volume so I'll be watching what
happens with price is price reacting to
these levels or not but when I start
seeing you know things like this four
contracts right the market sort of dip
below a level and you trade four well
that's telling me there Market was sort
of testing down here can we go lower
nope four contracts trade market closes
back up you know I'm always looking for
these areas where you know I'm seeing
just light volume and again you know
people are always looking at things like
the Dome and the heat map for areas of
big resting liquidity right that's the
whole selling point of things like a
dome or a heat map or a book map is you
can see the resting liquidity and yeah
that is great that
there's
good trade opportunities by knowing
where the resting liquidity is but at
the same time there's also great
opportunities by looking at a footprint
and seeing where there was I don't say
lack of liquidity but like little
trading going through right you can see
here right we hit the high sell off come
down here make a new low total of six
contracts
trade okay normally you're getting
anywhere from you know several hundred
to over a thousand now this is a bond
five minute chart let's take a look at
you know a much thicker more liquid
market right the the the five
years 5 years you know some price levels
you could be trading tens of thousands
of
contracts and this is where looking at
things
like lack of volume is is really going
to help you one contract trades you know
two contracts trade you know you're
seeing these volumes in here 3,000 3,000
2,000 7,000 4,000 right and you get 19
get
two right so you're always looking for
these areas where there's just small
volumes going
through right it came down in here look
at this right down into these lows okay
you trade three comes up about tick or
two comes down makes new lows right
trades 231 then it trades 33 contracts
so you have a Divergence here now
there's actually a bullish ratio If the
ratio is turned off here I want to get
to that later this week I'm talking
about ratios but
4,600 4,300
1,500 2700 and at this low on this bar
you trade just 33 where is
your selling it's just not there right
so while looking at resting liquidity is
good and and it's useful right I don't
get me wrong I I also like to look for
areas of volume right areas where you
know CU volume is is something that can
stop a move right imagine it's like
putting up a wall wall right you're
driving a car there's a wall there car
is going to hit it and generally stop
when it runs into um heavy volume the
Market's the same way but what people
often fail to also realize
is when there's nobody else trading at
that level and the market starts
reacting from it it often gives you a
good trading
opportunity so again I hope you guys
found this video
useful and if you did be sure to
subscribe to the channel so when we post
new video you'll get uh hopefully you
get a notification so thanks everyone
and I'll see you guys on the next video
bye-bye